again with uncle Moishe Oh who's gonna
care that about hierarchies SOS and all
that good stuff think of it right thanks
for coming thanks for waking up for the
morning session so welcome to part three
of the sum of squares tutorial so sum of
squares has a bit of a reputation as
being a kind of technical subject which
it is and some of the algorithms and
lower bounds in SOS are actually pretty
involved but what I want to do first is
I want to step a little bit outside of
my own comfort zone and tell you about
how SOS has a lot of implications in
other fields to explain especially to
theorists how SOS can say interesting
things in extremal combinatorics and
then I'll talk about some results in
polynomial optimization and tell you how
these are really intimately related to
quantum and especially quantum
information theory something called
quantum Definity theorems so I'm hoping
that the first part of this you're going
to get some idea of the reach of sum of
squares techniques and then I'm going to
conclude with you know some of the
recent lower bounds of the technology
and proving lower bounds especially for
plaintiff problems so they also gave me
this directive for the tutorial that I
should bore the experts and this morning
I ran into fan and Ron so let me tell
you you guys are gonna be super bored
you can just go to sleep for the first
part and Pablo you're gonna be bored the
entire time but let's do extremal
combinatorics and I'm gonna start off
with telling you one of the famous
results in extremal combinatorics which
is something which can be proven through
sum of squares and and semi definite
programming techniques so there's this
beautiful picture which was really
completed by raspberr off the last bit
of this
so what does this picture look like so
if you take any graph and you look at
the triangle density let's call that T
so that just means I take a graph and I
look at a random set of three nodes and
I measure the fraction of times that I
get an induced triangle on that set of
nodes and I also look at the edge
density which we can think about in the
same way a sample a random pair of
points and how often are they an edge so
you can ask for you know this particular
pair of sub graphs counting the fraction
of triangles and the fraction of edges
what are the allowable pairs of T versus
e so in fact this picture what it looks
like now it's completely understood so
obviously you have this corner at 1 1
where the graph is complete but you get
this curve that looks like T equals e to
the three halves and then you get this
little funny little shape down here
that's 0 along the 0 axis until the
point 1/2 and then you get something
very interesting happening that along
this other dashed line T is e times 2 to
the e minus 1 but you get these funny
little bumps all the way up and this is
the truth for this simple question that
if you ask overall graphs what are the
allowable pairs of the triangle density
in the edge density this is all there is
so this is a really beautiful picture
and to me this tells me already that you
know sometimes you see beautiful
mathematical works of art out of you
know fractals but you can also get them
out of sub graph densities for proving
things like this so what I want to do is
I want to explain a bit about how you
can prove ratios relationships between
sub graph counts and establish pictures
like this using semi definite
programming techniques of course this
area is pretty challenging so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to prove a
really simple
which is just that that the picture
looks like it does on this line that in
fact that if you ask for a triangle free
graph the largest fraction of edges you
can have is 1/2 so this is called Mon
tells theorem so let me tell you about
this theorem let's formally stated it
goes back a long way so it actually goes
back to 1907 and all it says is that if
you take a graph G and it's triangle
free so the density of triangles is 0
then the maximum number of edges you can
have is at most the floor of N squared
over 4
where just keep the notation simple
we're gonna have n is the number of
notes so this is actually such a simple
result that you know when I was
preparing this talk I realized that we
actually asked this as a question on our
undergrad discrete math final exam so
this is a really simple question I mean
we do give them a hint about how to go
about it via induction but let me prove
this really simple result that you could
get through purely elementary undergrad
techniques using some really high
powered machinery but the point is that
once you have this high-powered
machinery set up you can get lots of
beautiful pictures out of it and
understand really the cutting edge of
some of these results in extremal
combinatorics so this is going to be our
plan for the first part of part 3 let's
prove an asymptotic version of Montell
theorem that if you have a triangle free
graph the largest fraction of edges you
can have as 1/2
all right so in fact let me tell you so
this is really following a few works so
this is following a flag algebra
approach of fargöth ravi rubbery and
vaughn from 13 and in particular i'm
going to be following an approach of
Raymond Singh and Thomas which took the
flag algebra is approach of Rosberg
which he used to establish these types
of pictures and translated it into the
language of SOS so that we can
understand it you know in light of some
of the tools that Pablo introduced in
the first two parts of this tutorial so
this is our plan we want to use sum of
squares to establish this simple theorem
so first let's get started let's
understand you know how our sub graph
density problem can be translated into
polynomials after all that's what SOS is
about it's a relaxation for polynomial
optimization so the first key is well we
can define polynomials that count sub
graph densities
so let's see concretely how this works
so let me give you an example let's say
we take the graph h1 very simple graph
we have got a graph on three nodes with
just one edge between it so we can ask
for example if I sample a random set of
3 nodes
how often do I see h1 as my induced
subgraph so that's something that's a
simple probabilistic experiment but we
can also write it in the language of
polynomials so how would we do that we
define a polynomial D h1 which what it
does is it looks over all choices of
sets of three nodes and what it looks
like is it takes X IJ which you should
think of as the indicator for whether
the edge between I and J is present and
it counts all of the different ways that
this particular sub graph could occur so
for example this is one way that the sub
graph could occur and there gonna be 3
other terms depending on so for example
this is the indicator function of these
edges being missing so what this is
really counting is when we take the
triple ijk it's asking how often do we
have I and J here representing the edge
that's present and then are missing the
two other edges of course we get three
other ways to do this so we get this
polynomial let me just write it out just
to be concrete and we get the last term
is X JK 1 minus X election
okay so this is what I'll mean when I
talk about using polynomials to compute
sub graph densities all you do is you
take whatever your graph is and you
write out a polynomial using this type
of framework this is how we would do it
in the case of h1 you can define it
formally for you know all graphs using
injections but let's not do that let's
instead relate this back to sub graph
count so the point is that if we take
this polynomial dh1 and we evaluate it
on the indicator function of some graph
G so what I mean by that is we have n
choose two variables one for every pair
of nodes things like X IJ and all we do
is we take our graph G and we plug in a
1 for an X IJ if that edge is present we
plug in a 0 otherwise so the easy thing
to see is that the way we've done this
when we plug in the indicator function
of the graph G what the polynomial
evaluates to is it evaluates to the
probability that three vertices chosen
uniformly at random induce a copy of H 1
all right so now we're starting to be in
business we have a way to translate sub
graph densities into polynomials in the
name of the game is to try and prove
relationships between these polynomials
using the sum of squares framework but
in fact there is one more crucial
ingredient we'll need which is that this
result is only about triangle free
graphs so somehow we have to figure out
how to exploit the properties of the
graph namely that it's triangle free
when we're proving relationships between
sub graph counts so the way that we're
gonna do this I'm gonna strip away a lot
of the language that's usually used in
these papers because it's much simpler
in this one case we're looking at so let
me define the following I'm gonna let Z
of AI be the indicator function of all
graphs where G is triangle free the
reason it's written as Z of AI is
because a lot of times you talk about
this as the zeroes of an ideal we won't
really talk too much about this but
let's just define Z of AI this way now
the crucial ingredient is what we're
gonna do is we need a notion of when
polynomials are equivalent so we will
it's too low for me all right so we will
say that two polynomials P and Q are
equivalent mod this ideal if and only if
P of X equals Q of X for all X in the
zeroes of this ideal so let's translate
what this means this is our notion of
when polynomials are equivalent but it's
also the thing that's going to be
capturing the triangle freeness of our
graph because that's how Z of AI is
defined for our purposes so let's just
understand what this means
so what I claim is that if we let H 3 be
a triangle
then we can do the same thing where we
take this triangle and we write down a
polynomial D of h3 which for any graph G
we plug in the indicator function of G
and we plug that into the polynomial we
would get the density of triangles but
what I claim is that now when we're
working with this ideal that were
interested in where we mod out by these
triangle free graphs then what I claim
is that D of h3 this polynomial is
equivalent to the zero polynomial mod I
just using this definition because what
this means is that when we take any
graph that's triangle free which we plug
in to this polynomial its indicator
function of that graph we're gonna get
the same thing as we plugged it in to
the all 0 polynomial that's just because
this left-hand side counts the fraction
of triples that have triangles and there
are none of them by assumption because
we're starting off with a triangle free
graph so this is one this is a way to
illustrate what this definition means
and what working modulo and ideal buys
us is that once we have this ideal in
mind if working with a triangle free
graph we get some nice identities like D
of H 3 which is defined generally for
you know other graphs well once we're
working with this ideal it's equivalent
to the all 0 polynomial so let me know
if you have any questions but this will
be one of the crucial definitions so now
what I want to do is I want to start
using this technology about how to write
sub graph densities as polynomials and
how to work modulo and ideal to start
figuring out some elementary
relationships between the different
polynomials that will be characters in
the story so how do we do this so let's
let's define the sub graphs we'll be
interested in so I'm going to start off
with will have 3 sub graphs we can take
H 0 is the empty graph on 3 nodes H 1
we've already defined that's the same
thing H 2 is the 3 node graph which has
two edges and H 3 as we defined it is
the triangle graph so now for each of
these graphs I can write down this
polynomial D of H so
of h1 and so on what I claim is that we
get some simple identities out of these
things
what I claim is if we define a
polynomial D which counts engines so it
just evaluates to the edge density so
what is this polynomial all it is it
sums over all pairs of nodes X IJ so
when we plug in the indicator function
of a graph into this polynomial D all we
get out is its edge density now what I
claim is that we have some nice
relationships already that we can reason
about what I claim is that this is the
same polynomial as one third of D h1
plus 2/3 D h2 plus 3/3 dh3
so just to make sure we're all on the
same page can anyone tell me why this is
true
why these two polynomials are equal so
this is just another way to count the
edge density of a graph instead of
actually doing this experiment on the
left-hand side we choose two random
nodes and ask how often there is an edge
between them well we can instead do an
experiment where we count a triple of
notes and we look at how many induced
edges we get in that triple you know if
it's h1 then we get one out of those
three edges as present if it's h2 we get
two out of these three nodes these three
edges are present if it's h3 we get
three and there's no contribution from
h0 because it's zero out of three edges
but now what I claim is that this
polynomial is equivalent to one third D
H one plus two thirds d h2 mod this
ideal that we care about so why is that
that's because we already proved that
this guy is equal to zero once we're
working with triangle free
if you do this experiment on the right
hand side where you choose a random
triple of nodes and count how many
induced edges you have you never have to
worry about the contribution of the
triangles because by assumption there
are no triangles so this is already one
simple identity that's just the thought
experiment about doing a probabilistic
experiment one on the left and one on
the right in the language of polynomials
so let's prove one more elementary
identity before we get to something
called flags so what I claim is the
following that the all one polynomial is
equivalent to D H 0 plus d H 1 plus D H
2 mod the ideal so this is once again a
simple experiment see what you have is
that the all one polynomial is equal to
the polynomial D of H 0 D of H 1 plus D
of H 2 plus D of H 3 because what that's
really saying is that if you do an
experiment on the right hand side where
you choose a random triple of nodes and
ask how often do you get one of these
four graphs then you always get exactly
one of them so that's why one is equal
to that sum but once you work modulo the
ideal you know you never have to worry
about triangles so you can just cross
off that term once you're working mod I
so does this make sense any questions
about this alright so we've got our
technology in hand we've got our
language of how to use polynomials to
count sub graph densities we've got this
notion of working modulo an ideal that
takes a new account the structure of G
that it's triangle free and we have some
elementary identities we're gonna need
slightly less elementary identities to
prove Mon tells theorem which this is
going to take me to this notion of a t
flag so let me define this last graph
theoretic concept we're gonna define it
and then we'll talk about how to count
it using an appropriate probabilistic
experiment and get some last identities
that will be enough to prove Mon tells
theorem so let me define the notion of a
flag it's roughly the same thing
as we've been doing before we're
accounting subgraph densities except
we're gonna do it with some of the nodes
being labeled instead so this definition
is a little bit of a mouthful but it's
really crucial so we're gonna talk about
it flag which starts off with a little T
vertex graph capital T where every
vertex has a distinct label from one to
little T okay now the important point is
then we can use it to define a capital T
flag it's just a graph which has this
graph as its core so that's what this
definition is capturing so a T flag f of
size little F it's just the graph with
little F vertices and T distinct labels
from the set T that induces the core
with the correct with the labels being
correct alright so let me say this
informally because I warned you this
definition is a little bit of a mouthful
you start off with some core graph
capital T all it is is it comes along
with labels where every vertex in
capital T is labeled with a distinct
label that's the core and then this flag
is just some sort of ornate thing
hanging off of it it has the property
that hidden inside F is this induce
graft T with the labels being correct
and then there's some other vertices
which are not labeled which they can do
whatever they want so this is the notion
of a flag and the flags that we're gonna
use are actually really simple flags so
let's just define them upfront
the flags we're gonna use our F 0 which
is just the empty graph on two nodes and
has one label so little T is 1 and this
node is labeled down here as 1 and F 1
the other flag that we'll be interested
in is just this 2 node graph with a
single edge where this node is late so
these are both flags of a really simple
graph the graph you have this is capital
T right here is just the single node
graph that has a label 1 and these are
two ways of hanging off unlabeled
structures off of them to get the flags
F 0 and F 1 respectively so we're gonna
do is we're gonna define a way of
counting Flags actually pairs of flags
in a graph and we're gonna use that as
our way to create sum of squares proofs
about sub graph densities so the same
way that when we defined D of you know H
1 and other things like this there was
really a probabilistic experiment that
was sitting underneath it that I did
write out explicitly what D of H 1 is
but to do so for more and more
complicated graphs becomes a huge
mouthful and a large expression but let
me instead explain how to think about
counting pairs of flag densities as a
probabilistic experiment so and and you
should think about how this translates
into a polynomial
so I claim as we can count pairs of flag
densities let's call this pair for
example F and F Prime just for
simplicity so the idea is see when we
had this probabilistic experiment we
just chose a random subset of three
nodes and looked for an induced sub
graph we're going to do here is a little
bit different first thing we're gonna do
is we're gonna fix labels of T random
vertices mg and these labels as you
would expect are going to have distinct
labels from this set little T so first
thing you do in your probabilistic
experiment yep right so I'm adding
labels randomly so ask me the question
again when I get the full probablistic
experiment but what I mean by counting
pairs is this probabilistic experiment
is that we're gonna choose only the
labels in some set one through T we're
gonna choose those nodes randomly out of
the graph and then we're gonna choose
the unlabeled parts so what's the
remaining part of the probabilistic
experiment is remember that our flag you
know has little F minus T other vertices
that are unlabeled in this case just one
other vertex that's unlabeled so what
you do is you choose F minus T and
another F minus T because we're
interested in pairs of flags vertices
from G and what you look at is you're
interested in the probability that they
disjoint ly induce F and F Prime so
remember that these pairs of flags were
going to assume that they come from the
same chord graph T the same way that
these two flags come from the same
quarter F which is just the single node
graph with a single label and we're
gonna do is we're gonna do this
probabilistic experiment where we choose
where the core is by choosing a random
set of T nodes labeling them with
distinct labels and then we fix whatever
is the remainder in the two flags F
minus T notes for F F minus T nodes for
F prime and we ask what the probability
is that these two sets of nodes dis
jointly induce capital F and capital F
prime so what I claim is just to get an
idea of so this is the public experiment
what I mean by counting pairs of flag
densities but yep so when you choose the
it's joined from tea but are they also
destroyed from each other or you that's
a great question so this is so there's
always the subtlety that you can
actually choose them without these two
sets being disjoint but you're thinking
of little F and little tea is being much
smaller than the number of nodes in the
graph so there's a very low chance that
they overlap now these are the error
terms that are gonna come up in our sum
of squares certificates I'll say more
about that but this issue is a serious
issue it's just that it really won't
matter for our purposes because it will
contribute lower order terms so you
choose T random nodes uniformly at
random and then you choose a labeling
with distinct labels uniformly at random
for those T notes makes sense any other
questions
all right so let's try and understand
this probabilistic definition the same
way by proving some elementary
identities about these pairs of flags
that we have in mind I'll be good way to
make sure that we understand what
exactly this experiment is doing so
let's do that so I'm gonna call for
example let's look at D of F 0 F 0 which
is just the density it's the polynomial
that captures this probabilistic
experiment when both of our flags are F
0 and F 0 so what let's prove some
identity is about this so what I claim
this that this is equal to we can relate
it back to our original subgraph counts
in terms of the H is what I claim is
that it's actually the sum of these two
polynomials so if we do this experiment
where we you know choose a random we
followed this recipe and we count how
often we get the pairs of flags F 0 and
F 0 we can relate that to the experiment
of choosing three random notes where
when we choose three random note
we can ask the question condition you
know if we get h0 for example and then
we choose the rest of you know how we've
defined the flags the labelings right so
once we fix three nodes that's like
fixing the core and the things hanging
off the core but not which one is which
then you're gonna choose uniformly at
random from these nodes which one to
label one and that's what you would get
out of this probabilistic experiment now
the point is that whenever you start off
with the subgraph h0 as the thing that's
induced in your three nodes it doesn't
matter now where I place the core
wherever I place the core let's say it's
here so I label this guy 1 and this guy
becomes F and this guy becomes F prime
that's a case where we've disjoint li
induced a pair F 0 and F 0 so anytime we
actually find this empty three node
graph we're always gonna find the pair
of flags we're interested in so that's
one part of this identity is that every
time you get h 0 you're gonna get the
pair of flags in this probabilistic
experiment now the other parts more
interesting what if for example we take
H 1 that's the induced subgraph we find
on three nodes now we still have to
choose the remaining randomness in this
experiment where we label which node is
the core node and which partition looks
like this pair F and F Prime in our pair
of flats so this I claim if we started
off with this graph H 1 there's actually
only one way to end up with the pair of
flags F 0 and F 0 so can anyone tell me
what the only way to do it is exactly
right so the only way to do it is if
this guy is labeled 1 which if this guy
is labeled 1 it doesn't matter what
happens the other pair of flags because
that edge between them doesn't show up
in any one flag so disjoint Li these two
sets really do induce the pair of flags
F 0 and F 0 so this is already a very
useful identity for our purposes let's
do the same thing for other pairs of
flats and figure out what these
identities look like so it's just a sort
of fun combinatorial so let's look at
the pair
F 0 and F 1 this is the same thing as
doing F 1 and F 0 so let's do both
together now what I claim is that this
is one third D H one plus one third D h2
so this is more interesting let's look
at h1 for example so we start off with
inducing this sub graph in our triple of
nodes so what do we do what do we need
to do to be able to induce the pair F 0
and F 1 so what I claim is that they're
actually two ways of doing this see for
example we could have the label 1 here
and then we could have this being our
set F 0 then indeed we get F 0 here
correctly and for the other guy we get F
1 as we need so this is one way which
we're using the fact that we have a
third chance of labeling this guy is a 1
and we have a third chance of this set
being F 0 right bus yep
and so you can do this other ways too so
for example
so for example I could induce one down
here and have this guy being the pair
right this could be my you know F zero
down here this would be another way to
induce this pair of flags because I
would end up with F one up here so
really we have a third we have a third
chance of choosing this guy to be one
and then we have a half chance of
actually choosing this other guy to be
mated with him for F zero and the same
thing happens here so that's why we get
this one-third in front of this the H
one when we find H one is our subgraph
this is the contribution to this pair of
subgraph counts so this is H one's
contribution
let's do H 2's contribution so H 2's
contribution we start off with this
graph H two well what I claim is that we
need either the label one to be down
here and then we get this guy F zero
because then we miss this edge that goes
between them with F one is another way
to get this pair or instead what we end
up getting is we could for example have
this guy labeled one and we could have F
zero sitting down here and that's
exactly how you get this contribution
from H to the same way so let me skip
the other combinatoric but let me just
work out exactly what D of F 1 F 1 is
it's just elementary reasoning along
these lines so it turns out when you
look at the different sub graphs you get
1/3 D H 2 plus D H 3 when you look at
the pair of flags F 1 F 1 but now we get
to use our ideal so when we work modulo
this ideal of triangle free graphs we're
gonna remove this H 3 term and we get
just one third D H 2 mod the ideal so
these are all of the elementary
identities we're going to use the first
ones were just about sub graph counts on
how they relate to the edge density of
the graph these more sophisticated ones
were about pairs of flags which come
from this probabilistic experiment so
now in fact we have all of the
identities we need to prove Montello
theorem
yep sorry I mean safely invasion of
money so far what you're showing right
yeah the polynomials are just a
bookkeeping device some how are you
going to are you going to use some of
squares to say something better that's a
very good question
Ravi's right I better so let's do that
that's right that's right that's right
so we're gonna see exactly so if you
chose these separately this F minus T
and F minus T in a way that they weren't
necessarily disjoint there'd be some
chance that you would get a two node
graph because these things would collide
but the point is that that's actually a
very low probability event at something
that happens about you know 1 over n
fraction of the time when you're
thinking about these things being small
constants this is gonna show up in the
sum of squares proof that we're gonna
need an error term that accounts for the
fact that we do sometimes have
collisions it's not not yet yep we're
just using these two flags F 0 and F 1
it does this the sort of the factoring
the unlabeled vertex is on label it
doesn't actually matter at all right so
we could have really just looked at the
whole thing we labeled all three
vertices of the triangle that's right
that's right
so everything I'll be talking about is a
lot more general but you know just to
keep it simple let's work with just this
case so let's figure out now how to
actually prove mom tells theorem using
these identities so let me erase I guess
let me erase this part and keep up the
definition of flags and they're
probabilistic experiment but let's use
the identities we've developed so well
what are we gonna do we're gonna start
off with the half polynomial and we want
to subtract off this edge density
polynomial because we want to show that
for any triangle
free graph this is non-negative that's
our goal so we're gonna work modulo the
ideal and what I claim is first of all
just using this identity about you know
this identity - right here that one is
equivalent to D H zero plus the H one
plus the H 2 but it can just scale
everything by two and that gives us a
way to plug in these sub graph counts
over here right and we also have that
relation + 1 which expresses D in terms
of the other D H is so what you end up
getting when you do this out is just
doing the elementary algebra
you get 1/2 D H 0 plus 1/6 the H 1 minus
1/6 D H - this is all mod the ideal now
I'm going to do something a little bit
strange here which is I'm gonna add and
subtract off two terms so first I'm
going to group expressions into a more
convenient way so I'm going to make this
up minus 1/6 in front of the D H 1 I
still have the same - 1/6 in front of
the D H - and I need to add back in my
1/3 D H 1 in order to compensate for
moving this around so what I claim is
that this guy right here is actually a
sum of squares this is something which
is essentially non-negative up to this
error correction term about when these
two different flags collide so what I
claim is the following allow me to just
write out an expression and then tell
you what this thing means so why is this
actually a sum of squares is because
there are some other polynomials that I
can tell you what these represent in
terms of our probabilistic experiment
which you can write out this way
okay so what do I mean by this is when
we take a pair D F theta and D F prime
theta that's actually going to be the
same thing as D F F F prime plus minus
some error term where you're thinking
about this error term as really being
about whatever n so what this means is
that so you could first do an experiment
where you fix whatever the core is and
then you choose F and F prime uniformly
at random from the rest of the graph
into what fixes the rest of this flag so
all you're doing is you're actually
doing this experiment where you choose
the core theta and that's roughly the
same thing as actually forcing F and F
prime to be for example disjoint up to
some lower order correction terms about
whether or not these two flags collide
so the important thing is that this
matrix in the middle right here is PSD
and what you do is when you have this
identity that you know you could think
about this experiment with F and F prime
as coming from taking the core and then
fixing the two separately so that they
might or might not overlap well you
could interpret it instead as a
quadratic form where you're actually
looking at the expectation of this
vector against this PSD matrix so this
is where SOS comes in is just the fact
that this is a PSD matrix and this term
right here actually is sum of squares in
the sense that you can think about the
contribution of these terms as coming
from a probabilistic experiment which
whose contribution is non-negative so
this is where the action was happening
but once you have this what this means
is that
1/2 minus this edge density polynomial
plus this type of error term is actually
non-negative modulo the ideal because
this remaining this term right here is
not negative because we have this PSD
matrix and which is governing how we
construct this experiment and the only
other remaining term we have right here
is 1/3 times D h1 which is definitely
non-negative so this is how you can use
sum of squares to prove things like
Montell theorem is what this tells us
now is that you know just the trans like
what this means modular the ideal it
means for any triangle free graph
because that's what we substitute in
when we talk about working modulo the
ideal we have that half minus the
density of the graph when we evaluate it
at the indicator function of G Plus this
epsilon this extra slack term is
actually non-negative that's what this
inequality modular the ideal means so
this actually proves Mon tells theorem
but it gives you a sense of how you can
actually prove interesting relationships
about sub graph density counts using
things like sum of squares the idea is
trying to find some interesting
identities some things on the sub graph
counts are starting off with and
guessing the right flags that are going
to show up in your sum of squares proof
and then figuring out how to get the
desired inequality which holds you know
modulo the set of graphs are considering
yep h1 you haven't shown this dh1 the h1
is non-negative only when I evaluate it
at the indicator functions of graphs
it's just something that's non-negative
because it's a sub graph density count
so what I have is that I can express
half minus the density of my graph
modulo the ideal of these triangle free
graphs
as a sum of squares coming from this
experiment about pairs of flags plus
something non-negative and that's the
proof of Mont Alistair so to show that
this expression okay this expectation
yeah so what you would really do is you
would you know just figure out what this
probabilistic experiment is and handle
these types of collisions and then just
the fact that it is a PSD matrix which
are taking a quadratic form of some
vector yeah exactly
because this is just some average of non
negative terms right so for example this
is the part that you would check right
here is that when you actually do this
experiment where you end up choosing the
core theta randomly that you can look at
the expectation of this pair of these
polynomials which are two independent
experiments and the point is that you
actually get a relationship to the pair
of experiments F and F prime where you
choose them you know disjoint wait for
example up to some extra slack term
exactly so for example when you actually
want to check this expectation so first
of all I use these so I used only one
and two the identities to prove this
part right here because I just expressed
half and the edge density in terms of
the subgraph counts but where I actually
used the inequality of the identities
about flags wasn't going from here to
here so this is the thing that you check
is that if you have this quadratic form
you can figure out all of the different
terms in this quadratic form they all
look like things like this for different
pairs F and F Prime and then I can use
this identity about how that relates to
the different pair of flag experiments
that we talked about and then I use all
of those identities to figure out that
this is the same thing as this so this
is some algebraic calculation by just
looking at the that's you know how do
you you want to answer keys right
good idea then they started sending
polynomials in monomials with integrity
so you having in practice able to accept
this infant the big flags up to a
certain size will be called flag
acceptance of the size and how do you
find that matrix in there
you saw resume today so this is the part
of you know proof system that's
automatize about up to some degree or up
to some you know number of extra nodes
in the flag exactly exactly exactly yeah
exactly
any other questions about this yeah I
mean is there if you were to look at
that expression sort of and stared at an
elementary way would you be able to
prove without sum of squares that it
really amounts to the yes dienes of this
guy in some sense the flags so important
why do we have to start labeling I like
why wouldn't we be able to get it
without label graph because we need this
type of you know in order to express it
as a quadratic form in this way we do
need to talk about you know how looking
at different experiments in isolation
looking at just the experiment for F and
just the experiment for F prime relates
to the pair fix the composite experiment
for F and F prime and that really
requires talking about the common core
that's being fixed that's what's
happening within this theta as that's
what's enabling the sort of sum of
squares proof is the fact that you're
allowing some part of it to be labeled
so that you can figure out how these two
things interact with each other yep
which size the this yeah yeah it's
because we're looking at pairs of flags
which there's one node in the core and
then there's one node outside the core
both of the two flags because we look at
F 0 and F 1 so that's why we're always
choosing when we try and relate to that
experiment about pairs of flags to our
original subgraph counts which is what
we did in these different identities
that enabled us to go from this to this
style of expression that's why we need
to talk about triangle counts here was
because of the pair of flags we had in
mind the right side would yeah then you
need some pretty fancy things yeah yeah
much larger it's not quite this simple
yes yes definitely definitely a lot of
fun yeah so a lot of times you can talk
about you know
SOS using a constraint something like
boolean ax t so that I'm going to come
to actually when I transition to the
next topic which is something called
pseudo expectations which is a dual and
complimentary view to the view that
Pablo introduced in the first two parts
of this tutorial
that'll be the mechanism by which we get
some of our algorithms and the
connections the things like quantum
after the second line feels like what
you owed in a sailboat with like this
the F 0 F 0 and so on so what you do is
you go from the second of a third line
using this set of identities exactly
perfect
all right yep
so you know something that's you know
this is a huge topic outside but you
know something interesting you can ask
you can ask all sorts of relationships
about pairs and higher order k tuples of
sub graph counts and it's kind of
remarkable is a result of hamed how to
me that shows that actually figuring out
which types of inequalities about sub
graph counts are hold for all graphs and
which ones don't is actually an
undecidable problem so eventually you
know you encounter some pretty scary
beasts and this type of thing now these
types of you know this isn't razz Braatz
original version but this is a version
of it view from SOS which you can use to
fully resolve this picture about
triangle counts versus edge densities
but when you go out to the most general
versions of the problem you will
encounter undecidable problems in this
landscape
all right so we're actually somewhat
close to the end of the first hour this
was supposed to take a little bit less
time but that's okay I'm gonna cut some
stuff at the end so maybe now there's a
reasonable time to take a break and what
we'll do is in the second in the in part
4 of this tutorial I'm going to explain
how to around sum of squares algorithms
using a probabilistic viewpoint and how
that actually relates to some very
fundamental questions in quantum
information theory so one of the things
I really wanted to get across in this
tutorial is that you know SOS connects
to all of these other areas in math and
physics and sometimes you hear about
these connections but actually seeing
what they mean in an elementary language
is a bit non-trivial so once we get to
quantum we're gonna see how polynomial
optimization and results about how well
SOS performs relates the things like
quantum Definity theorems that I'm going
to explain
I promise without any bras and ket's all
right so let's end there for the time
being
I did any final equation so it's um it's
a way to translate fly elder Bruce into
the SOS language which the crucial thing
is you know how to make sure that the
semi-definite programs that you get out
are constant size so it heavily uses
some results of Pablo and gatorman which
use representation theory to say that
when you have symmetries in the
optimization from your solving that you
can work with much more restrictive sets
so the sort of virtue of you know
rosboroughs fly algebras approach is
that they're always constant size types
of things now they can be prohibitive to
actually solve these things off to some
degree but you know how to get all of
the flag algebra machinery working
within SOS with constant size so many
different programs what is it by
computation as in you want you know if
you're looking for constant size proofs
like a fifth-degree beanie you
definitely don't want your semi-definite
program to run an end to the d time
where n is the number for instance so
you want it to run at some constant
amount of time that you know for
constantly and it's the number of nodes
in the graph there is no anything
again okay but if you want to prove it
for example I mean there are certainly
ends and the number of variables in
these yes they're also an issue with so
for example this is actually a weaker
form of Montello theorem already because
you know mom tells there was extremely
sharp like it first of all didn't have
it said you know floor of and squared
over four now first of all this is an
asymptotic version that you know we get
that 1 over 4 in there but because of
these error term you see the inequality
were proving about subgraph densities
already has the slack up to something
that goes to 0 within so that's a you
know property of these types of proofs
that when you translate between the F
Prime and this expectation over beta the
F theta d-theta you are going to
encounter these types of overlap you
know these error terms that accounts for
overlaps and collisions between the two
different ones so that's one aspect is
that actually what we did was we gave a
very high-tech proof for a slightly
weaker result than mom tells theorem
which as I promised you we do and under
Greta Street
I guess people are using the [ __ ] out
yeah the fly that if you do annoys me
you repeat it
well I mean so it that work of Raymond
at all what it does is it connects okay
actually could you brother machinery of
Glassboro what's there
it's been there for several years and
people verified
I saw yep
I'm at the further explain the toy I
mean somehow the main point they have
been a really great point that line on
Kevin's in that paper he said Larry
essentially say that you can recover
that the flag algebra is nothing but
when you take some of squirrels and you
know symmetry reduction and you let them
go to infinity and then kind of flags
have nothing but in a sense learn organ
of the equivalence classes that you get
when you've gone into the action of the
of the symmetry group in the India
synthetic limit and only finitely many
in traditional representations are going
to appear in the symmetry in the
composition of these polynomials and
those irreducible representations are
exactly Flags
retrospect won't up just done you know
the flag stuff without being personal
no but any point I mean what I think
it's perhaps right now if you ever try
to read rustle of papers I mean that
paper lineup without some understanding
the big picture or whatever it was
really mystery I mean not just to I
think many people have learned of this
sense of they know ok wonderful theory
you can compute lots of things how do
you ever think about I know the end of
doing these kind of things and somehow
really I think was a very nice link from
the notion of somehow a very concrete
question about ok I really just want to
show non-negative II do not know kind of
a polynomial the problem in terms of the
number of polymers for infinity so it
would seem as if you would have to solve
like a semi definite problems of size
that grows within but line of your
essentially when you look at this then
your synthetic version and I don't you
ignore this I mean you program you can
ignore these order 1 over N terms then
everything becomes having collapses to
do this harder to make it
do we know then the reach of what flag
algebra is canon cannot prove is there
some delay well delineated threshold or
is that I mean there are still you know
pretty elementary open questions of the
hypergraph versions of these things
where we don't even understand the
asymptotics for the count so it's the
second we I mean we there's still plenty
of interesting things where we don't
really understand what all these
techniques could be used to prove what
but in the sense of like how the
positive selling sucks to tell you that
like you know any reasonable and
equality if you go up to high enough
degree you can prove it but there are
things which are undecidable we can only
return this what can be shown with the
concept of the flies so if you if you
were to let the number of flags go to
infinity we then then you understand
that's always that's always the game in
these types of things is we don't
understand you know what the power is
for being the T being a small constant
beeping what rhythmic that kind of thing
so this is a great time to segue until
you know quantum where the D really
represents you know when you create a
composite of states how symmetric they
are and how close they've become the
nicer more classical objects that we can
reason about their the name of the game
is always having some quantitative
balance in terms of D but the same way
here are some of the mystery is what can
you get out with constant sides you know
priests are it
so again
[Applause]